اذكر حضراتكم ان اوروبا كان فيها خمس دول
تلتزم سياسه الحياه منذ سنوات طويله هذه
الدول الخمسه هي سويسرا والنمسا وايرلندا
وفنلندا والسويد لماذا الزمت فنلندا
والسويد نفسهما بسياسه الحياد اي عدم
الانضمام لاي احلاف عسكريه قصه طويله لكن
روسيا في القلب منها اذكركم ان فنلندا
كانت جزءا من السويد من القرن ال 12 حتى
القرن ال19 وان فنلندا والسويد خاض حروبا
طويله مع الروس حوالي 11 حربا كبيره كان
السبب الرئيسي لهذه الحروب الكثيره هو
الصراع على منطقه النفوذ في بحر البلطيق
وبحر البلطيق نفسه وكانت اخر الحروب بين
السويد وفنلندا التي كانت جزءا من السويد
وروسيا هي حرب فنلندا عام 1809 وانتهت هذه
الحرب
بتنازل السويد لروسيا عن منطقه فنلندا
وانتقلت فنلندا منذ هذه الحرب الى
الامبراطوريه الروسيه لتصبح دوقيه فنلندا
الكبرى حتى عام 1917
بعد هذه الحرب 1809 تغير مصير البلدين
بشكل كبير زي ما قلت لحضراتكم فنلندا
اصبحت جزءا من روسيا وبالنسبه للسويد بدات
تشعر بالاعياء والاجهاد من الحروب
المستمره في اوروبا سواء مع الروس او مع
غيرهم وبالفعل قررت ان تلتزم سياسه الحياد
والنائي بنفسها عن الصراعات الملتهبه في
القاره العجوز وكانت اخر حرب خاضتها
السويد في اغسطس 1814 كانت حربا مع
النرويج ومنذ اغسطس
1814 لم تخد السويت حربا واحده اي ان
السويد لم تحارب منذ اكثر من 200 عامل
وتبلورت سياسه الحياد بدايه من 1834
والتزمت بها حتى اثناء الحرب العالميه
الاولى والحرب العالميه الثانيه
اعود الى فنلندا فنلندا اصبحت جزء من
روسيا حتى عام
1917 وفي عام 1917 اندلعت الثوره الروسيه
او الثوره الشيوعيه وفي ظروف يطول شرحها
طلبت فنلندا الاستقلال وحصلت عليه واصبحت
دوله مستقله وظلت كذلك حتى عام 1939 عندما
عندما اندلعت الحرب العالميه الثانيه في
اجواء الحرب العالميه الثانيه كان الكل
خائف من الكل كل الدول خائفه من الدول
الاخرى وفي اطار هذا الخوف العام قررت
المانيا تحيد السوفييت في صراع المانيا مع
الدول الغربيه الاخرى ووقعت معه اتفاقيه
عدم اعتداء في اغسطس 1939 لكن ظل الاتحاد
السوفيتي خائفا يتحسب لغزو محتمل من جانب
المانيا وبدا في اتخاذ مجموعه من
الاجراءات لتامين نفسه وكان احد هذه
الاجراءات
طلب به تغيير الحدود مع فنلندا والفنلندا
تعالوا ندخل مفاوضات انا عاوز منكم برزخ
كريليان ومنطقه كريليان منطقه نزاع
تاريخيه بين السويد والروس وعاوز منكم
مجموعه جزر في خليج فنلندا وخليج فنلندا
جزء من بحر البلطيق
وعاوز منكم تاجروا لي يعني
ميناء هانكو عشان اجعله يعني ميناء عسكريا
او قاعده عسكريه بحريه في مقابل اعطائكم
اراضي بديله رفضت فنلندا فقرر الاتحاد
السوفيتي فرض تصوراته ومطالبه والحدود
الجديده مع فنلندا بالقوه في حرب الشتاء
التي حدثتكم عنها الحلقه الماضيه والتي
بدات في نوفمبر
1939 وانتهت في مارس 1940 وكما قلت لكم
حرب الشتاء او حرب فنلندا
السوفيت الاولى
اشتهرت لانها فنلندا على عكس المتوقع كبرت
الاتحاد السوفيتي خسائر فادحه لكن الاتحاد
السوفيتي تمكن في نهايه المطاف رغم
الخسائر الضخمه من الحاق الهزيمه بفنلندا
واجبارها على الاستسلام لمطالبه لكن كان
من نتائج حرب الشتاء ان هتلر وجنرالته
رقبوا ما جرى وادركوا ان الاتحاد السوفيتي
ليس الا نمرا من ورق وان جيشه الكبير عددا
لا يمثل خطرا على المانيا وانه لم يكن على
المانيا ان تخشى من احتمال مواجهته
وبالتالي قرر الالمان غزو الاتحاد
السوفيتي متاثرين بالاداء المتواضع جدا
للسوفيته في فنلندا كانت كل هذه الخسائر
يعني حدثت في صفوف السوفيتي في مواجهه
فنلندا الصغيره كيف يمكن ان يؤدي السوفيتي
في مواجهه المانيا العظيمه غدا الالمان
السوفيتي في يونيو 1941
وبمجرد ان قام الالمان بغزو الاتحاد
السوفيتي قررت فنلندا الانضمام الى
المانيا ليس حبا في المانيا ولكن رغبه
منها في الثار لنفسها واستعاده الاراضي
التي استحوذ عليها سوفيت بالقوه في حرب
الشتاء
انتهت الحرب العالميه الثانيه كما نعلم
بهزيمه المانيا ووجدت فنلندا الصغيره
نفسها مره اخرى في مواجهه السوفيت
الجيش العملاق المنتصر واجبرا فنلندا على
الاستسلام لكل مطالب السوفيتي في معاهده
وقعتها عام 1948
بموجب هذه الاتفاقيه سامح السوفيتو
لفنلندا بان تكون دوله مستقله لكنها
ملتزمه بسياسه الحياد اي ان لا تكون جزءا
من اي كتله عسكريه يمكن ان تمثل خطرا على
الاتحاد السوفيتي
وهكذا خرجت فنلندا بدرس قاسي جدا من الحرب
العالميه الثانيه اول درس ان الحياد هو
افضل سياسه ممكنه لضمان سلامتها واملها
واستقلالها وعليها ان تراعي طوال الوقت
المشاغل الامنيه للاتحاد السوفيتي ثم لرسل
الاتحاديه بعد ذلك الدرس الثاني انه ما
حكى جلدك مثل ظفرك وعليك ان تحاول تطوير
قدراتك الذاتيه للاستعداد لاي غزو محتمل
اخر من الاتحاد السوفيتي او روسيا
وبالتالي طورت فنلندا الصغيره مساحتها 340
الف كيلو متر مربع
بينها حدود تصل الى 1340 كيلو متر مع
روسيا الاتحاديه عدد سكانها صغير خمسه
ونصف مليون لكنها تمكنت من تجييش المجتمع
كله
واجراء سياسات كليه خلاصتها كده انها في
حاله استعداد دائم لغزو محتمل من السوفيتي
سابقا او من روسيا الحاليه
وعليه فنلندا اصبح لديها جيش قوي
سواء قوات بريه قوات بحريه قوات جويه الى
اخره الدرس اللي تعلمته السويد هو ان
التمسك بالحياد هو افضل خيار ممكن لانها
حتى بعد انتهاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه
كان يمكن لها ان تنضم لحلف شمال الاطلسي
لكن غالبيه الاحزاب والقوى السياسيه في
السويد كان تقديرهم ان هذا سوف يكون ضارا
بالجميع دارا بهم دارا بفنلندا ضارا بحلف
شمال الاطلسي لانه اذا هي انضمت كان هذا
سوف يحفز الاتحاد السوفيتي احكام قبضته
على فنلندا وتغيير الحدود مره اخرى
وبالتالي ليكون قريبا من الحدود السويديه
الامر الذي سوف يهدد السويد والامر الذي
سوف يجعل من حلف شمال الاطلسي على شفا
مواجهه مع الاتحاد السوفيتي وبالتالي
تمسكت السويد اكثر به سياسه الحياد ورحب
الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف ش الاطلسي بهذه
السياسه وارتاح لها السوفيت ثم ارتاحت
اليها روسيا ما الذي تغير الذي تغير هو
الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا في 2014 ثم 2022
هذا الغزو اثار حاله من الفزع والهلع في
المجتمع الفنلندي والمجتمع الصيني ولسان
حال كثير من القوى السياسيه هناك اذا كان
الروس فعلوا ذلك بابناء عموماتهم ماذا
يمكن ان يفعلوا بنا وارتفعت نسب المؤيدين
في البلدين للانضمام لحلف شمال الاطلسي
لمستويات قياسيه في فنلندا كان نسبه
المؤيدين تاريخيا للانضمام الى النيتو
مقابل الراغبين في الالتزام بسياسه الحياد
حوالي 20 الى 80% في مايو الماضي تغيرت
النسبه الى العكس واصبح نحو 80 في المائه
من الاهالي فنلندا يرغبون في الانضمام الى
النيتو مقابل 20 في المئه يرغبون في عدم
الانضمام والنسب ايضا تزايدت لمستويات
قياسيه في السويد هذا هو السبب المعلن اما
غير المعلن ولكنه واضح جدا هو ان فنلندا
السويد دول حلف شمال الاطلسي استانست لحظه
ضعف في الدوله الروسيه ورات انها بما رات
انه بما ان روسيا عاجزه عن حسم الحرب في
اوكرانيا وواقعه تحت ضغوط سياسيه وعسكريه
واقتصاديه ضخمه جدا هناك فمن غير المرجح
ان تتمكن من فتح جبهه عسكريه اخرى ضد
فنلندا او ضد السويد باختصار السويد
فنلندا دول حلف شمال الاطلسي ينظرون الان
الى روسيا كما نظرت المانيا الى الاتحاد
السوفيتي بعد اداءه الهزيل في بدايه الحرب
الشتاء ضد فنلندا سنه 39 وسنه 40 ماذا
يمكن ان تفعل روسيا حقيقه الامر ان روسيا
واقعه في موقف بالغ الصعوبه بالغ الاحراج
لانها شنت حرب اوكرانيا
وهدفها الاساسي قطع الطريق على انضمام
اوكرانيا لحلف شمال الاطلسي فاذا بفنلندا
التي تشترك في 1340 متر حدودا والسويد
القريبه جدا منها يسعيان للانضمام الى
الحلف ما يجعل
روسيا في موقف يعني يضطرها اضطرارا للتحرك
ضد فنلندا وضد السويد والتحرك محفوف
بالمخاطر الامر الذي يجعل المستقبل مفتوح
على كل السيناريوهات والمحرك الاساسي هو
الخوف فنلندا والسويد الخائفه تسعى
للاحتماء بحلف شمال الاطلسي حلف شمال
الاطلسي الخائف يسعى لتامين نفسه بالضم
فنلندا وضم السويد روسيا الخائفه سوف تسعى
للرد بنشر صواريخ نوويه تكتيكيه
واستراتيجيه ويعني تكثيف التواجد على
الجبهه الغربيه للدوله الروسيه نشر صواريخ
تكتيكيه واستراتيجيه
سوف يثير الخوف في حلف شبال الاطلسي فيرد
بخطوات مماثله وهكذا ندخل في دائره جهنميه
مفتوحه على الجحيم